bonjour il charme nigauds merci beaucoup
merci d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france alors le ghana a
reçu ses premières doses de vaccins
financés par le programme kovacs il
était temps absolument il était temps
parce que après des mois d'attentes les
populations africaines étaient
réellement dans la tente en voyant les
autres pays à commencer les vaccinations
donc c'est exactement une très bonne
nouvelle pour l'afrique mais également
pour les dispositifs kovacs donc ces
dispositifs kovacs est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer comment ça marche
les vaccins sont livrés gratuitement
mais qui finance ce dispositif
en fait le dispositif kovacs a été
lancée par l'organisation mondiale de la
santé mais également gavi l'alliance
pour les vaccins et seppi pour en fait
essayer de jouer la carte de la
solidarité de l'équité au niveau global
en essayant de disposer des vaccins pour
les pays les moins développés à ce qu'il
puisse avoir un petit problème de
connexion malheureusement les vaccins le
même temps qui désole a donc le
financement s'est fait par un mécanisme
de solidarité au niveau international où
la communauté internationale les
donateurs m l'argent semble pour acheter
les vaccins pour les pays effectivement
en voie de développement accor vous
expliquer le fait qu' on est attendus
minimum trois mois pour pouvoir
acheminer ces doses au ghana par exemple
écoutez il ya un gros problème pour le
moment sur le plan international c'est
que les pays les plus développés où les
plus riches ont fait des précommandes
des vaccins avant même que ces vaccins
les soirs mis sur le marché et on nous
nous sommes retrouvés dans une situation
où certains pays ont commandé 5 6 fois
la quantité des vaccins dont ils ont
besoin alors que les autres pays en voie
de développement ne pouvait pas avoir
les vaccins
donc c'est réellement une situation
assez inédite que nous sommes en train
de vivre est effectivement kovacs
de vrais avait comme objectif a toujours
comme objectif de d'essayer de pallier à
cette situation d'inéquité au niveau
international pour que tout le monde et
des vaccins en même temps et puis se
protéger contre cette pandémie
mais en même temps d'ailleurs l'onu a
demandé à ce que le vaccin deviennent un
bien pour l'humanité évidemment vous
êtes d'accord avec ça absolument parce
que tant qu' une partie de la de la
communauté internationale ou des pays
servira à protéger les autres ne s'en
repart protéger donc on n'aura pas
suffisamment de protection n'est qu'au
global dans c'est une affaire
effectivement de solidarité et de biens
global a donc la situation des variants
par exemple de nouvelles variantes vient
nous rappeler que si nous ne vaccinerons
pas rapidement et mettre enfin cette
pandémie
nous risquons d'avoir des nouvelles
variantes qui vont en fait anéantir tous
les bénéfices que nous avons jusque là
obtenu avec la vaccination même dans les
pays à développer près un milliard trois
cents millions d'africains 270 millions
de doses de vaccins à distribuer cette
année on est loin du compte quand même
on est loin du compte mais les choses
bougent
les choses avancent le dispositif cauvin
que ça vise plutôt à donner 600 millions
six cent millions de doses qui vont
vacciner à hauteur de deux doses par
personne environ 300 millions de
personnes mais il ya également l'union
africaine une africaine qui va compléter
ce dispositif
effectivement mettant en place ces 270
millions de doses dont vous avez parlé
effectivement son euro africaine
pardonnez moi oui exactement
donc nous espérons qu'avec là la
conjonction de ces deux efforts au
niveau continental le dispositif kovacs
et l'union africaine
nous pouvons au moins vacciner dans un
premier temps jusqu'à 40% de la
population est effectivement aller au
delà à 6 allée vaccin deviennent
disponibles d'ici la fin de l'année
comment est-ce que c'est perçu cette
guerre des vaccins en europe avec dédé
des populations qui parfois rechignent à
se faire vacciner
comment est-ce que du continent africain
c'est perçu c'est un sentiment je dirais
mixte parce que d'un côté il ya beaucoup
de pays
beaucoup de personnes qui attendent ces
vaccins qui réellement veulent se faire
vacciner mais de l'autre côté on voit
des pee wee à l'accès gratuit à ces
vaccins
les gens résignés les gens hésité à se
faire vacciner
entre temps nous continuerons à voir et
à perdre de vie au niveau du continent
donc comme il est vrai qu'il ya une
certaine hommes je dirais réticences
également dans certains pays mais de
manière globale à les populations
africaines attendent de se faire
vacciner attendent de se faire protéger
donc c'est vraiment un paradoxe au
niveau international où certains riches
en les vaccins mais n'en veulent pas
alors que là où les gens veulent
réellement se faire vacciner
il n'y a pas de doses de vaccins on a vu
le sénégal lui a commencé à vacciner sa
population la veille de l'arrivée des
vaccins du système kovacs au ghana le
sénégal qui s'est approvisionné auprès
de la chine et qui va le faire bientôt
auprès de la russie donc les vaccins
sont plus accessibles dans ces pays là
j'ai un peu tout le paradoxe que le
dispositif kovacs voulait éviter en fait
que les pays soient obligés de faire ce
genre de démarche
je dirais unilatérale et s'organiser
eux-mêmes pour accéder à des vaccins
nous le voyons au sénégal aujourd'hui
avec l'arrivée des vaccins sinophone on
a beaucoup des négociations également à
5 effectivement le piste à roddick et il
se tourne
là où ils peuvent avoir des vaccins à
disponible et c'est tout à fait normal
pour pour le moment bien que
effectivement nous conseillons pays
d'avoir plutôt accès à des vaccins qui
sont autorisés par l'om en ce sens et
nous espérons que ces vaccins que ce
soit le vaccin chinois ou le vaccin
footing 5 auront bientôt
l'agrément effectivement qui est attendu
au niveau de ses victimes en loups gars
c'est pas que ça puisse être
effectivement distribués partout
merci beaucoup richard nigauds pour
toutes ces explications ce matin en
direct sur arte france